hey guys it's Justine and today we're
doing a drill review in quarantine yeah
definitely something that I never
thought I would be doing but here we are
and we're gonna make this happen this is
the new magic air - and I do plan on
doing a follow up video when we're
allowed to leave the house again let's
unbox it smell of fresh technology
something I love this room kind of falls
somewhere in between pneumatic air and a
Matic pro too far sighs this is closer
to the Matic pro if this controller is
actually quite massive
it doesn't have an LCD on it whereas
most of the higher-end drones do I just
pop this up put our phone in it now that
I kind of like let's see what's in our
accessory box so we've got it's a USBC
au charger adapter all the cables that
we'll need to connect our phone to the
controller and our propellers these are
very clearly marked as to where to put
them so there's a and B and I rip the
stickers off so if you did rip the
stickers off there are silver markings
on the top of the propellers and that
silver marking matches up on the top of
where you'll put the propeller these are
the B propellers and they're black how
am I going to review this drone in my
house
[Music]
this is the Mavic air two and this is
the first time the DGI is bringing some
other high-end drone features to a
mid-range drone with the starting price
of $7.99 you'll get the drone a battery
and the controller the controller
features occu sync 2.0 which will allow
you to get video transmission up to 10
kilometers and for us basic Americans
that's over 6 miles all right let's put
this in here I do kind of like the
placement of this I like that it's above
instead of below like normally when
you're flying you'll have your screen be
here Matthew I'm trying to do a drone
review but I like the placement above
actually a lot better all right I'm
gonna download the app update my drone
and then I'm not gonna go outside and
fly it I'm going to stay in the house it
shoots up to 4k 60 video and up to 1080
240 frames a second for some incredible
slow-mo it also will shoot 8k hyper
lapses HDR video and photos and up to 48
megapixel photos in one mode it features
all of our favorite DJI quick shots
hyper lapses Panos smart photos and of
course focus track spotlight active
track and points of interest these are
all things we've seen in previous DJI
drones so it's always great to see them
back again and even better with a pas
3.0 obstacle avoidance this will log the
drone to detect and avoid upcoming
obstacles by flying over or around them
this roam will get up to 34 minutes of
flight time that's the best flight time
so far out of any of the Mavic drones
this is DJ eyes first consumer drone
that includes air syns technology it
provides safety warnings to drone pilots
that there's other aircrafts nearby
since the pandemic has created supply
chain issues that's out of DJ eyes
control the Maddock air tube will
initially be available in two versions
one with air sense receivers and one
without
since the FAA has implemented the
strongest requirements for airplanes and
helicopters in the US the air sense
version will be sold here in the US and
the non air sense version will be sold
in other countries I think the future of
drone flying is gonna be really
interesting for us everyday consumers
there are a lot more restrictions of
places that you can fly so be sure to
check your
Maps before you head out because there's
nothing worse than heading to a location
that you think you're gonna shoot and
guess what you can't fly there so we're
outside can't really fly this very far
at all since I am in my backyard I can't
go anywhere all the beaches are closed
all the parks are closed because of
quarantine I'm gonna fly it a little bit
in my backyard just to see how it flies
maybe I can do a very short hyperlapse
throughout the backyard and then I'll
fly it a little bit in the house I do
have some crop guards for it so just in
case I hit the walls or anything just
can't say it walls for anything turn
avoidance so we can free
[Music]
[Applause]
do you remember when I said I'm gonna
turn obstacle avoidance off and do you
remember when I also was talking about
the prop guards that I didn't put on
there's a reason for that friends
because I now have cut a hole inside
these curtains
learn from my mistakes this is this bad
behavior and this is now I'm paying the
price
[Music]
I thought maybe we would test out some
of the slow-mo let's try the 240 frames
a second
[Music]
bored in the house sent them in the
house bored now what are you gonna do
dude I don't know
this looks so good I've been flying the
matic mini for the past several months
so going back to a higher-end drone
looks so amazing
the matic mini is so great because it is
small compact it's extremely portable
and very light but if you really do want
to get good quality 4k HDR video you
definitely do need to get a bigger drone
but this looks so amazing I can't wait
to take it out I wanted to show you guys
a size comparison between the brand-new
Mavic air 2 and the previous version of
the Mavic air this was a really great
little 4k drone it had twenty-one
minutes of flight time you could shoot
60 frames a second at 2.7 K but the
biggest downfall was the Wi-Fi
transmission you'd only be able to get
four kilometres at 720p but with the
pneumatic air 2 you can get 10
kilometres at 1080p found nothing 4k 60
on that
[Music]
I've been flying DJI drones for quite a
while now and it's been interesting to
kind of lay these all out and do some
side-by-side comparisons here's the
mattock err the Mavic Pro 2 and the
Mavic mini I've done unboxings and
reviews on all of these drones in the
past if you guys want to check those out
feel free to check the links in the
description most recently I've been
traveling and using the Mavic mini the
most because it's so small and portable
even though it doesn't shoot 4k the
footage still looks really good and the
fact that it's so small there's no
excuse why I don't always have it with
me
the Matic Mini has been geared towards
beginners but the fact that it doesn't
have obstacles this might not be the
best drone for somebody who is just
starting out if you are looking for an
inexpensive drone
yes Mavic meeting is perfect but if you
want that confidence of having obstacle
avoidance Navigator 2 might put your
mind at ease when you're out flying
thank you guys for watching you join us
actually outside applying heard your own
right now
I'm gonna put a link in the description
if you guys want to check out this drone
and get more information or if you want
to purchase one I know this review is
not one of my typical drone reviews so I
look forward to further covering this in
a later video from the meantime
definitely put prop guards on if you
plan on flying in the house at obstacle
avoidance is our friend for the most
part unless you want to fly reckless
[Music]